welcome
um and I want to especially welcome um
Brent Amy and Justin uh Justin mulling
Amy Cook and Brent uh Fraser and uh I
apologize again to them they were here
last week and we didn't notice it notice
this in the procedure according to
protocols so they were still nice enough
to come back and this will be recorded
for the folks who aren't here uh to
explain and tell us to take some
questions with regard to uh uh a number
of Veteran related issues from the
hospital um to uh I I met Justin uh two
weeks ago a suicide
prevention uh event up in
Plymouth so uh thank you for being here
and for passing out these wonderful
materials and we have some folks that
are inbound and like I said this is uh
being
recorded So we we'll we'll lead off with
uh uh just
and
Amy and then Brent and
uh as soon as Justin's
done sharing these uh these
goodies we'll uh we'll start with
him share a story yes and and I want to
thank representative Carrie too she was
a prime mover behind this uh information
uh professional development session
representative
Carrie uh thank you representative
Moffet and um part of the reason for
having this session today uh has to do
with one of our committee members who
shared a story with me uh he is not able
to be here today he has to work but he
asked if I would share his story um he
is himself a veteran representative
finny and um he found himself in crisis
in such crisis that his friends said to
him if you don't go to the hospital now
we will call the police because that's
what we know to do in the community
right if someone's in crisis we don't
know what El to do send them to the
hospital or call the police so he did at
the behest of his friend go to the
hospital and the hospital examined him
and released him with no assistance
whatsoever and so he is very concerned
because he said you know when I was in
the
military you knew if you were in crisis
you kept it to yourself you sucked it up
and you worked through battled through
your demons and he said but going to a
hospital admitting that you had demons
and that you were struggling and then
being turned
away to go back and do exactly what You'
had done while
serving he found that very very very
difficult and um I can't tell you in in
the line of business I'm in how many
similar stories I've heard over the 33
years I've been in business of veterans
sharing the same and and some don't make
it some don't they end up at the Veteran
Cemetery um and I think all of us would
like to see some better outcome than
that thank you so much representive
carry um Justin welcome we'll start with
you uh I mentioned I met you up in
Plymouth recently I have your business
card but if you could uh start off by
just telling us uh if you weren't
already going to tell us uh you know
what what you do and then uh you can get
into some of the things that you think
we should be better aware
of thank you for having me Mr chairman
representative Carrie appreciate you
reaching out to the VA um my name is
Justin meing I'm a resident of Lichfield
I'm a social worker by
trade uh I have been working at the
Manchester VA Medical Center for
approximately a year and a half uh prior
to that I was working at the Jamaica
plane VA down in
Massachusetts uh I am a veteran myself I
was in the Coast Guard for six years and
I am also a client of the
VA um I am fortunate in that it's
because of the VA that I was able to
become a social worker it was through
Vocational Rehabilitation that I was
able
to get to where I am today I'm very
grateful
um what I'd like to do is start a little
bit from sort of the larger picture of
the overall VA suicide prevention
program and then that will uh uh sort of
naturally come down to what I do and a
little bit more of what's Happening Here
in New Hampshire
um the Veterans Crisis Line that folks
are potentially familiar with if you
dial 988 and then press one rather than
reaching the local uh Crisis Line you
will get transferred to the va's
Veterans Crisis Line where we've got uh
train clinicians answering phone calls
247 a while back we just had one call
center in Upstate New York over the
years we've tripled in size and we have
uh call centers in Upstate New York
Atlanta and in Topeka
Kansas the 988 press one for the
Veterans Crisis Line it's available to
All Veterans and anybody that's
concerned about a veteran
the folks that answer the phone are uh
prepared to talk to somebody who uh
either is with somebody who's in crisis
somebody who is in crisis or somebody
who's concerned about somebody in
crisis
the the um folks on the other end of the
phone line they start by just getting a
sense of what's happening for that
individual and triaging the situation
they have the ability to get Emergency
Services underway to support that person
if that's what's needed that does not
always happen it doesn't have it's not
an automatic roll out like if you called
911 the at the end of the call depending
on how things go if the person would
like they can be referred and connected
to their local VA at which point uh that
call then gets referred locally to our
Suicide Prevention
coordinators that
are they're tasked to follow up of those
calls within 24 business hours so it
makes a difference if it's a weekend or
not but they are responding to those
calls on a regular basis they do
follow-up case management referrals on a
case-by casee basis veter veterans at
risk are tracks they're
monitored um the Suicide Prevention
coordinators provide both internal and
Community Based suicide prevention
training uh VA saave training is
available free to Community Partners and
stakeholders uh and that's something
that we've been doing in the last
year
um through and coordinated by The
Suicide Prevention coordinators we have
our general mental health clinic so that
winds up being part of our Suicide
Prevention
structure full range of mental healthc
care is available um either at at our
local VA or folks can be referred to one
of the other medical centers in the
region um we have the entire VA at our
disposal as
needed um the VA offers what we call
Same Day Access if somebody walked in
the idea really centers around the no
wrong door approach which means if
somebody walked in off the street
somebody would be able to meet with them
now what that tends to involve would be
triaging the situation identifying if
there's a crisis and if we need to
respond in a crisis situation we would
do so accordingly uh and then it's if
it's more routine then that person will
leave with a referral when an
appointment to come back uh but the idea
being that we've have folks that are
ready to support veterans
um at any point in time during our
business hours uh that is one of the
um sort of unique aspects of the
Manchester VA is that we are not a full
service Medical Center um
the two full service medical centers uh
that folks may be familiar with that
have emergency rooms in the full uh
range of care uh are White River
Junction I uh central Massachusetts and
the Boston area uh there are other
medical centers in around Manchester has
an Urgent Care uh Bedford has an Urgent
Care um and then there's also various
ancillary services that are available
there as
well uh the mental health service has a
mental health case manager it's a nurse
who's assigned with a assisting with the
facilitation of transfers between
facilities or between emergency room and
Community providers so if somebody
showed up to the Elliot emergency room
and Elliott is looking to get that
person transferred to right River
Junction just for an example this is
somebody who's there to who's working to
build those connections and make those
um transitions as smooth as
possible my role is part of the
community based interventions for
Suicide Prevention it's a fairly new
program when I was hired about a year
and a half ago uh this was a new
position for the Manchester VA the idea
is that with over half of veterans that
are eligible for VA care choose not to
pursue their care at the VA for us to
have a true impact on veteran suicide we
need to support our veterans in the
community where they're getting their
care and get beyond the walls of the
medical center
C the VA VA has identified that the that
the best way to get out there and
to uh quickly multiply that uh effort is
through community coalitions and
building coalitions my job is to build
those community coalitions support our
uh Partners in the community uh in order
to um approach Suicide Prevention from a
public health perspective that includes
training Community folks in suicide
prevention and how to talk to somebody
who's in crisis and where to find
resources it includes
encouraging uh folks in the community
that are supportive of veterans to
Advocate with their local providers to
encourage them to screen in order to
identify veterans because if we're not
asking if somebody's a veteran or not
then we can't get them Services uh New
Hampshire is um a national model with
the ask the question campaign uh the VA
uses New Hampshire as a model for that
um and the whole point is to really
encourage as much as possible as
universally as possible to ask folks
have you or someone or loved one ever
served in the military you ask that
question and then the idea is you also
have to support people in what to do
next if the person says yes then what um
and that's part of what we're working to
do from this public health approach uh
there
are we have
about there's eight total coalitions in
the state so far that came together in
the last year one of those coalitions is
a little bit more administrative it's
it's kind of designed to bring people
together to facilitate the process of
creating coalitions so it doesn't quite
apply but it fits the definition we have
coalitions and the
um we've got the stronger together
Coalition is out of Milford out of the
addiction recovery Coalition of New
Hampshire greater Manchester veteran
Suicide Prevention Coalition is hosted
by both Easter Seals and uh Forge Health
uh with Sean kilber and Stephanie
higs um
the uh svent County Veteran Suicide
Prevention Coalition they recently named
themselves Granite hope they are hosted
by the West Central Behavioral Health in
Claremont uh with Bill metcoff SE Coast
veteran Suicide Prevention Coalition
recently got started uh through the SE
Coast Public Health Network and cement
the Arison Carol County Veterans
Coalition hosted by the Carol County
Coalition for Public Health
in uh led by Jen Thomas Capitol area
veteran Suicide Prevention Coalition
they're about to have their first
kickoff meeting that's hosted by um the
capitol Area Public Health Network uh
with Ashley Sullivan Vanessa Healey and
kayn omok uh I mentioned these folks
name because I encourage folks to track
them down especially if you if you have
if you know folks that might want to be
involved or if you want to learn more
especially if these are folks that are
from your District District uh central
New Hampshire Coalition it's hosted by
Central New Hampshire Katie out of
Plymouth
um that's turning out to be a wonderful
Coalition they've got some great
connections with pouth State University
uh and will be interesting to see how
that comes together um the last thing I
wanted or or the last Coalition I wanted
to mention that folks may be familiar
with is the Lakes Region Veterans
Coalition that actually came together
under a program before I was even hired
uh that was out of the VA Office of
rural
Healthcare but the structure of that
program overlaps almost perfectly with
my job and my role and the nature of the
program so we sort of just kept that
within the umbrella of all of them
together that is uh that contact for
that is Kurt Weber um it's up there
connected with C Brazilians they're
really doing some wonderful stuff um
that's probably if you think about the
age and development of a community
organization they're the most developed
with the border of directors and bylaws
and they're Incorporated and that sort
of thing um the last piece that falls
under my purview as a program
coordinator uh involves the uh New
Hampshire well it's the national
Governors and mayor challenge in New
Hampshire uh the New Hampshire
Governor's challenge uh for the
prevention of suicide for service
members veterans and their families uh
that that Pro that project or that
program now lives within the New
Hampshire Suicide Prevention Council and
the military and veterans committee of
New Hampshire Suicide Prevention Council
the uh of which I co-chair with Amy
Cook um so that's a brief overview of
all of the different aspects of the va's
approach to Suicide
Prevention and I that sort of Segways
into um Amy's presentation thank you for
having me here
today thank you Justin and uh same thing
Amy if you can I know you've changed
jobs during your your journey so if you
could update us and on where you're
where you are and then uh tell us some
things that we we should know better all
right good afternoon my name is Amy Cook
and you have a folder in front of you
that I passed out you'll notice that my
business card um and my email address is
with nami New Hampshire I started
working there in January of
2023 yes a year ago I did think for a
second um but I'm here today in my role
as the chair of the New Hampshire
Suicide Prevention Council the co-chair
with Justin of that council's military
and veterans committee and the team lead
for the New Hampshire Governor's
challenge to prevent suicide among
service members veterans and their
families prior to moving to Nami New
Hampshire I was the um division director
for the the division of community- based
military programs at the New Hampshire
Department of military Affairs and
veteran services for many years um when
it first opened in 2019 I had already
been in that position at DHHS for about
a year and a half at that time so come
with great experience working in the
community-based uh sector of this field
and really a passion com coming from a
military family um with a strong strong
growing up military right my parents
grandparents we have a Medal of Honor
recipient Pearl Harbor Survivor Vietnam
veteran um OE OE o combat veteran um and
the the list goes on and on so I grew up
thinking that the military was all
parades because my grandfather and my
great-grandfather you know marching in
parades with them um it was for me it
was all about balloons and excitement
there's a school named after my
great-grandfather in Massachusetts and
it wasn't until I became an adult um and
really started to work in the field to
know that it's not all balloons all the
time you know from the the story that
representative Carrie shared in the
beginning there's really some gaps in
Services um I have not served myself but
I I see myself as an advocate for those
who have I know for my own family
experience typically and for those of
you who are veterans I imagine you might
find yourself in the same position that
sometimes it's hard to be the person who
advocates for yourself you know it just
feels strange sometimes so I love to
step into that role and say yes this is
what we need to do for our veterans um
so I'm I'm so incredibly happy that
Justin asked me to join him today so in
that folder that I gave to you the one
thing that I'm going to refer to the
most is this um this big piece here that
has the wheel in the middle of it so
when you're re and please review it I I
put together the folder because I knew
we were limited on time so I expect it
to supplement what I'm just going to
highlight here for you today so I won't
be offended that you're reading through
it looking at it and not looking at me I
encourage you to do that um but when
reviewing this document that I just
showed you that has a whole bunch of
Suicide Prevention initiatives for
veterans in New Hampshire I hope that
two notable aspects will be apparent to
you first the broad spectrum of services
and supports that are available and
second the high degree of collaboration
that exists between the VA State
departments in New Hampshire and
Community providers so suicide
prevention for veterans is undeniably an
important public health issue demanding
a comprehensive and multi faceted
approach to make a meaningful impact
addressing the challenge necessitates an
approach that goes beyond individual
mental health counseling it requires a
broad array of services that span Mental
Health Care Community Support education
and Outreach initiatives for the
military and Veteran community in
particular um representative Kerrie had
touched on this in the story that you
shared in the beginning mental health
awareness campaigns play a pivotal role
in reducing stigma and encouraging
people to seek help when they need it
accessible and effective mental health
services including counseling Crisis
Intervention are imperative components
of of the supportive system but
additionally community-based programs
fostering social connectedness
resilience and early intervention
contribute to significantly to
preventing suicide they all relate to
that wheel that you see in the middle
that
really personifies the quality of life
for a veteran here in New Hampshire
collaboration between healthc care
providers Educators you as policy makers
and Community leaders like us here are
essential to create a unified front
against the Public Health Challenge of
suicide so we really need to emphasize
ongoing research policy development and
resource allocation to truly make a
difference in the lives of our New
Hampshire
veterans the VA the New Hampshire
Department of military affairs and
veteran services the New Hampshire
Suicide Prevention Council and Community
providers are really the primary
stakeholders leading New Hampshire's
Suicide Prevention efforts collectively
those entities we focus our efforts um
using the national strategy for
preventing veteran suicide the cdc's
preventing suicide technical package New
Hampshire's state Suicide Prevention
plan and the one you're probably most
familiar with New Hampshire's 10-year
mental health plan
so notable Statewide initiatives um that
are really briefly mentioned on this
this handout for you that I really want
to make sure you know about are first
the governor's challenge to prevent
suicide among service members veterans
and their families Justin mentioned that
it started in
2018 um samama and the VA began
supporting teams under this program in
New Hampshire proudly we were one of
seven states to start in that inaug year
um since that time we've been active in
developing goals and action plans
implementing and meeting objectives
tracking outcomes and just continually
assessing needs so the team continues to
meet monthly we're very active as Justin
mentioned we're now embedded in the New
Hampshire Suicide Prevention Council so
that we can have some sustainability
there increase our Network um and the
impact that we have so this team
primarily focused its efforts on
educating New Hampshire providers about
military culture and suicide prevention
promoting the ask the question
initiative that Justin mentioned and
supporting the development of the local
veterans coalitions in this past year I
actually had the privilege of going down
to work in Washington DC last week with
the last eight teams to join the
governor's challenge one of those um
State teams so seven seven States
including Maine actually is one of the
last ones to join and the Commonwealth
of Northern Mariana Islands so it's
exciting that now all 50 states and all
US territories have a Governor's
challenge team the other thing of
notable interest is the staff sergeant
Parker Gordon Fox Suicide Prevention
grant program it's a big mouthful um but
it comes with a lot of responsibility it
comes with a lot of funding so we are
super excited to have a recipient here
in New Hampshire which is Harbor care so
they were awarded this uh Suicide
Prevention Grant during the first round
of that Federal program they've
developed and are implementing at this
time a comprehensive array of services
focused on suicide prevention for
veterans um and they're collaborating
with other Statewide groups and the
local veterans coalitions as well and
then lastly state funded Suicide
Prevention projects EAS seals New
Hampshire and partnership for public
health were selected through a
competitive RFP Pro process by um the
department of military Affairs and
veteran services last fiscal year to
implement services to reduce social
isolation um and increase access to
Mental Health Services for veterans in
New Hampshire so this funding
unfortunately was a one-time allocation
it ended last June however both
organizations are really continuing that
work that they started with the funding
so they're now in the process of trying
to figure out how to access different
funding sources to keep it going or to
at least build on what they did do so it
doesn't completely
end um and then lastly and kind of
related to that Easter Seals as you may
be aware um they were provided an
allocation of State funding to move
forward with some really Innovative
plans to develop a veterans campus in
Franklin New Hampshire so that's going
to offer veterans across New Hampshire a
comprehensive array of services to
address many of those social determin of
Health that you see on that wheel um
from that handout so the good news is
that's a lot the good news is that there
is a lot the good news is also that
between 2018 and 2021 the New Hampshire
veteran suicide rate continued to
decrease um we don't yet have official
numbers for
2022 um we're hoping that there's a
decrease because of
covid I'm optimistic but kind kind of
holding my breath a little bit um there
are a good number of services and
resources available to Veterans who want
our help our state has a proud history
of collaborating across sectors and
industries launching Innovative programs
with little to no resources um as you
all know to be described as Grassroots
in New Hampshire is a source of Pride
for many
organizations um but there definitely
are some areas where we need to make
some improvements for our veterans the
highest rates of veteran suicide occur
in the rural areas of New Hampshire
despite the existence of many you know
of that this shows and that I talked
about many services and resources
veterans and their families are often
unaware of their existence or they have
trouble navigating them um I often say
that New Hampshire veterans don't have a
resource problem they have a navigation
problem and one reason for that is our
lack of a large active milit
installation that often serves as a hub
of information you know a place where
people can get referrals and services
and connect with each other it serves as
a way to disseminate information for the
state department but we don't have that
here in New Hampshire as you know we're
a National Guard State um so we just
need to do a little more creative
problem solving so many Grassroots
initiatives crucial for veterans lack
sustainable funding here in New
Hampshire relying on private grants or
donations often leading to stunted
growth or eventual dissolution numerous
nonprofit organizations provide
essential services for veterans uh but
their Reliance on unstable funding
jeopardizes their continuity for
instance we had the military liaison
program which was initially funded by
DHHS um and the Medicaid balancing
incentive program starting back in
2015 it had some positive outcomes
including an increased uh TR care
enrollment for our community mental
health centers the model gained national
attention many states have replicated it
but in fortunately funding ceased in
2017 and by 2018 only one cmhc still had
a military liaison so without financial
support these Liaisons instrumental and
fostering military cultural competence
within their organizations and
communities were asked to revert to
billable hours in their organization so
they went back to providing services
like Clinical Services um rather than
acting in that military liaison role so
it really hindered the organizational
capacity to serve veterans effectively
sustainable funding is imperative to
ensure the longevity and impact of these
vital programs as the question initiated
in 2015 is another prime example of New
Hampshire's commendable initiatives um
Al also initially supported by DHHS and
bip funding the campaign featured a
website a logo a Statewide plan for
military culture training and has served
as a model for other states in just the
past year alone I've done consults with
about 20 other states who want to
develop their own ask the question
campaign but despite its National
influence New Hampshire's effort
stagnated after the funding ceased in
2017 in contrast many states have
surpassed New Hampshire they've
established legislation and allocated
State funds to guide and sustain their
ask the question campaigns um so even
though I continue to help them develop
and get going um they quickly you know
surpass what we've done and we lag
behind but the good news is that there's
so many opportunities for New Hampshire
to strengthen Suicide Prevention
initiatives for
veterans um the establishment of a
Statewide closed loop referral system by
DHHS that's hopefully going to be
implemented this summer I am super super
excited about it'll allow policy makers
and leaders to identify Trends um in
service seeking among our New Hampshire
veterans and assess the obstacles that
they're facing in accessing accessing
those Services I expect it to make it
easier for veterans to find what they're
looking for and get connected to the
care that they need through that davs
recently convened stakeholders to
identify a path forward for ask the ask
the question campaign so this provides
an opport opportunity to Breathe new
life into that campaign bring new
partners like New Hampshire Hospital
Association to the table and hopefully
Identify some new resources as well to
make it sustainable and then I also
included in your um in your folder uh a
list of what some other states have done
I did a benchmark study recently for my
own purposes just to see what other what
other states have done and what we might
learn from them so I thought it was
really applicable here today so I I
popped it in there for you when you scan
through those examples you'll notice
that many states have passed legislation
mandating um that service members and
Veterans be identified in places such as
hospitals State Department programs
Corrections programs um or social
service
agencies the identification is then
linked to providing that veteran with
appropriate resources So currently not
all New Hampshire emergency departments
hospitals healthc care agencies or
Community Mental Health Centers have
effective practices to identify someone
who has military service some of them
ask at intake um some of them do not but
even for the ones that do ask the
followup when the answer is yes is
lacking or not meaningful at all um when
I've ask people oh great you you know
you do identify service members and
Veterans what happens after that the
answer is usually like well somebody
must know I'm sure the case manager does
something you know and then the you
follow up with the case manager and the
case manager is like oh I didn't even
know we asked so there's not really good
policies and practices um around that
and the legislation and some of the
other states has helped to guide those
entities to move forward with that so
looking at what other states have done
is definitely an opportunity that we're
going to seize in the coming year um
other examples you'll see are creative
Innovative programs and resources that
help veterans find the care and services
they need and easily access them almost
all of them have been supported by
federal Andor State funds so they can be
scaled expanded Statewide and
sustainable which is the most important
part so funding allocations as we move
forward here in New Hampshire need to be
clearly marked for a specific veteran
initiative in order to guarantee that
those funds will be used in the ways
that they were intended Grassroots is
exciting it's flashy everybody takes
pride in it um but it's not what we owe
our veterans I believe that we we have
we owe our veterans a level of
commitment that's sustainable and not
just flashy and Grassroots so as we The
Suicide Prevention Council military and
veterans committee move into 2024 we
plan to critically assess our
achievements over the past five years
and what's required in the next three 3
to 5 years to meet the needs of New
Hampshire veterans and continue
decreasing the rate of new the New
Hampshire veteran suicide rate so I hope
you can tell that I'm super passionate
about what I do can obviously Jus and I
can both answer questions now if there's
time but you do have my business card so
please please follow up if you have any
questions or if you even just want to
get coffee and talk about the veteran
landscape in New Hampshire I'd be super
happy to do that so thank you so much
thank you a wonderful presentation and
wonderful handouts um I'm sure there's a
couple of questions probably percolating
but um Brent Fraser is here too um Brent
did you want to uh come up and um sir I
think um for Mr chair thank you uh for
recognizing me and it's it's great to be
here I think after both of what Justin
and Amy provided uh I would just like to
express on behalf of the Department of
military Affairs and veteran services
wholehearted support uh to the the va's
whole of nation uh Health uh benefits
program as well as what Amy described in
terms of New Hampshire's uh Suicide
Prevention programs particularly the uh
the military and Veterans programs the
department of military Affairs and
veteran services is a partner with both
uh they've outlined the programs and
while I think probably most of you all
are aware there's a little over 94,000
veterans across the state of New
Hampshire most are doing very well uh
they've got good jobs they've got the
educational opportunities they own their
own homes but if you look uh a level
below that if you look at the suicide
numbers across the state of New
Hampshire and really if you you peeled
back what Justin uh alluded to in terms
of the national numbers uh the numbers
for veteran suicide both Across the
Nation and in the state of New Hampshire
are nowhere near where they should be
one is too many and we have uh well over
one in the state of New Hampshire as Amy
mentioned our numbers are coming down
somewhat uh from uh 2020 20 to
2021 uh the 2020 new number 22 numbers
are still pending uh and so we will see
where those go uh but I think they very
eloquently described the programs and
initiatives that are getting after the
problem uh and we would just support
those problem uh those uh programs and
initiatives uh going forward so I'm here
uh in support and subject to any
questions that you might have uh for our
department uh to be able to provide
reinforcing fires to to what they shared
with you
all thank you so much Bren
um questions for uh represent Carrie if
you want Mr chairman if you don't
mind there's always one more thing um
one of the things I wanted to add was
one of the initiatives that came about
in about the last year or so for the VA
is the compact act and I think it's very
important that folks know about that um
that legislation that came out pretty
much in the last year so allows for
emergency Psychiatric Services to be
paid for by the VA for most veterans who
are other than dishonorably discharged
uh which is a tremendous expansion of
services to Veterans um there are some
specifics as far as eligibility is
concerned um but it provides 30 days of
residential care and 90 days of
Outpatient Care uh for a total of 12 120
days for somebody who's in that crisis
situation that also includes if an
ambulance ride is needed to get to the
ER and it doesn't have to be a VA
facility it's it's wherever the veteran
wants to go or whatever the local
whatever the nearest support is um
there's some other eligibility issues
whether somebody's a reserve or garden
how long they've been active for uh but
that's something that you know sort of
those details can get sorted out with
the case managers and the um folks that
manage that but I think it's it
important that folks know about that
that that's
available thank you for that Justin um
representative Carrie yes uh can you
tell me how
veterans whether active or or out of
service get this information that we've
gotten today how is H how do they know
to act access service do you you know as
they're signing out say oh by the way
here's a little pamphlet for you how do
they get this
information you just described one of
the challenges that I think those of us
in the
sorry in the veteran
services World struggle with is getting
that information out there uh while it
doesn't apply to every situation what is
common is when you've got somebody who's
leaving the service transitions in care
transitions from um life transitions are
um known to be risky situations for for
uh veterans um when somebody's leaving
active
duty they're focused on housing they're
focused on getting a job they're focused
on doing a lot of
things and many times but not always
there is you know it's later on that the
person starts thinking hey I need I need
to connect with the VA that person may
have gotten the information about what
to do when they got out of the service
but they might not have been ready to
hear it so
we're every veteran service organization
that I've encountered in New Hampshire
has been eager to get the word out to um
you know things like event calendars and
uh sort of getting the word out these
are things that it's it's definitely a
challenge we talk I talk about it with
the coalitions that we've built how do
we get the word out how do we connect
with veterans in the community and it's
not easy uh but it doesn't mean we're
just going to stop we keep doing doing
it uh I know the the va's got social
media presence many of our Coalition few
of our coalitions have uh just try in
different ways uh to connect but I I I
appreciate your question because it is
probably one of the biggest challenges
right follow up follow up one of the um
the questions that was asked of me was
that is there any way since it seems
like every veteran regardless of their
personal situation has a phone is there
any way you can text links to services
or that sort of information via their
phone so that they have it with them
whenever it is that they need it one of
the things I did want to add from your
previous question then I'll get to that
um the VA does have social workers
working in the mil and the milit in the
military to VA program it's a
transitional program social workers
whose job is is to help veterans
transition uh from their care and and
Military medical support to the VA but
again the challenge is we have to
identify the veterans um we have to get
the word out that's where the the New
Hampshire asked the question campaign is
really wonderful uh and it's um just
constantly pushing it out
there uh a comment for you all um I just
had a note or mention from my researcher
there is a Health and Human Services
uh oversight committee um it's chaired
by representative Mark Pearson I'm not
sure if you've had any interaction with
that committee with Mark but but I would
recommend if that you make a note uh
Mark Mark Pearson is a state
representative he's actually used to be
with Health and Human Services committee
he now chairs the child and family law
Committee in fact he he and I he and US
share that office right there um so uh
mark would be in his over oversight
committee would I think be a wonderful
uh potential uh resource to interface
with so uh would encourage you to reach
out and disconnect with with
representative Pearson his son's in the
legislature too this is Mark the the
father uh
who's say
inter yeah the son right Steve is is the
Son and Mark is the is with the uh
oversight
committee uh anything else other
question representative
mow you were mentioning that you have
eight coalitions throughout the state do
you have anything above the
notch the the furthest up that uh we've
been able to organize folks is Conway
which is Carol County and then we have
uh the central region in Plymouth um
there are some challenges when it comes
to catchment areas when you get above
the knot that's White River
Junction
um the um there's a lot of great
programs up there we've reached out one
of the things that is uh really been
great as I've learned about New
Hampshire Amy mentioned the Grassroots
efforts around the state uh there's a
lot of great folks out there that are
working on these things there's some
really great supports already existing
up in um the North Country uh but we do
not yet have a coalition there but we're
also not done building coalitions either
so possibly in the future hope so well
if I can help you let me know okay thank
you representative Mass is from
Littleton which is just barely in the
North Country some people argue if it is
or it isn't I'm from gron originally
which is definitely North
Country um anything else I represent uh
sh
well thank you all for being here today
um just my own story I served in Vietnam
and carried a lot of baggage back with
that and I had the bright idea that if I
went back to Vietnam to see it the way
it is I'd stop remembering how it was
when I was there and I went back seven
years ago and of course the Luck of the
Irish I arrived and it was the iners
with the unification of the north and
south and everywhere I looked there was
a picture of hoi men looking down
smiling on me and um I was supposed to
be there 10 days but I had to leave
after 8 cuz places that I went to where
I knew things happen especially during
tat was now in Nestle's or Michelin or
some Corporation was there and um I came
back and saw our counselor and she was a
wonderful person but it was like I was
talking a foreign language when I try to
explain things like you know what
different phrases and things meant and
she didn't seem to understand and I
think there is something you know we
talk about um functional alcoholics I
think there's a thing called functional
people with some form of mental health
that do have college degrees are working
in professions but in part of my concern
about going to VA was I felt there was a
stigma a stigma attached to that and so
but this person I saw I saw her about
four or five times and she was terrific
but she had no idea in a way and I think
it was probably because more me than it
was her so I eventually went to VA and
that was the best thing I did cuz there
everything that I was afraid about VA or
heard about it was just the opposite and
once a year now I get a call from the
doctor saying how's things going you're
okay and you know and they always
reaching out and so so like I think
sometimes we think it's the lower
economic segment of our communities that
struggle but it can be anybody at any
time and um and uh and if you're a
Vietnam vet don't go to Vietnam in
September representative Shir lfty um
thank you for your service and I
think are there other veterans on this
committee thank you as well just wanted
to recognize that again we're talking
about the ask the question campaign I
figure it makes sense we should do it
here um but um and listening to your
story I really appreciate that one of
the things that we've been doing in the
military and veterans committee is
really looking to promote military
culture training um it's a little bit
more than just understanding rates and
ranks and branches of the military it's
understanding a little bit more about
how Soldiers and Sailors and Airmen
think and behave and act and things that
they expect and
um when a clinician has taken that extra
step to try and understand that culture
better veterans can feel that if that
makes sense uh and that's important uh
and that's something that we look to uh
continue to spread that training around
the community one of the initiatives
with the Lakes Region Veterans Coalition
is they've put together a training of
Suicide Prevention military culture and
uh selfcare and they've been presenting
that to the Lakes Region Community
College EMT program they're expanding
that to the the nursing program there as
well um
and these are folks that are entering
the field who are going to be taking
care of folks in the community um and
you know ideally these folks have a leg
up to be able to address some of the
issues that you've
identified R did you a hand up
y
yes uh listening to representative
shirtliff we had discussions on that I
was in a Navy during the Vietnam era I
never served in combat I never got into
a fight except with other
Shipmates now when I get out of of the
military I went to work was a police
officer in Manchester for a time as a
matter of fact representative sheriff
and I were we were to the academy
together back then in
1970 I did go through an anti-war
demonstration which uh
which kind of messed me up a little bit
not suicidal I never thought of being
suicidal but there was only four of us
against around 250 and I thought my life
was over and I had something clicked
inside my head and I remember thinking
to myself it was either I had a pucker
Factor if you can be gross either fight
or flight something clicked in my head I
I said if I'm going down today
somebody's coming with me and I started
lashing back and I was
we were all pretty effective until the
rest of the uh cops showed up thank God
and not everyone who were demonstrating
wanted to get involved in the fight but
there were some in there who every time
you tried to make an arrest you get
pounded in the back so you let the
person go they were hoping that you'd go
into the crowd then you would me and I
remember I couldn't shut it down that
night when it was all over and went back
you know you you need okay gagy go back
to your rout and I I asked the captain I
says Captain I say I need to go home
says why you're police officer you go
out there and do your job I says I don't
feel right I you know I couldn't put it
into words you know you're a police
officer man up keep that to yourself go
out there and finish your roof well I
ended up shooting somebody that night
because they were getting away and
another one who not going to get away
that absolutely representative shirtliff
knows about this story
absolutely Ru ruined my career as a
police officer because I didn't want to
do it
anymore and
and I got over that but I had I had uh
flashbacks for about oh a year and a
half two years after that I would
yelling at the bullet to come back into
the
gun literally yelling and I'd wake up
and and my wife would say what's the
matter I said I had that dream again
I'll crying out loud right the
thing was in my estimation that they did
not have someone there who could talk
you down and calm you down and but by
goly sends you home to rest up because I
couldn't click off I I was looking for
trouble I was looking to get
somebody and and they couldn't
apparently they couldn't get that
through their head I can't identify with
some Soldier Marine anybody who's been
in combat
so there's no way that I could uh
counsel with them because I wasn't there
I didn't know any of that stuff but I
was there when I was getting hit and I
was hidden back and I wasn't going to
survive that's how I felt and if
somebody that night would have a captain
would have said yeah go home Larry and
you know think it over and just relax
and you know give me a call come and see
me come and see this chaplain whoever I
think I'd retired as a police officer
with h I was up for sergeant after two
and a half years you know because I was
doing my job but that just absolutely
ruinous so no because nobody wanted to
listen that's my thank you for that
representative gagy and thank you Amy
and and Brent and Justin um we're going
to take up a Senate bill on an Irish
trade Council you're welcome to stick
around for that if you'd like um and and
thank you again thank you again for your
patience and having to make two trips
here very much appreciated thank you I
just want to encourage folks in the
stuff that I gave you has my contact
information if you want to share that
with anybody else or if you're
interested in connecting with me outside
of this discussion today I'd love to
follow up and hear what um what your
thoughts
are thank you Jus represent Rollins
question any of your business cards with
you because that's easier for me to keep
in my wallet if we could get one of
those this one that's yeah I got that
one that's Amy oh that's Amy yes I can I
have business cards okay thank
you
welcome Mr Speaker we were just going to
have representative schliff who is very
Irish introduced this measure but you
are here and do you mind if we ask you
to introduce it we'll call this hearing
to
order uh and Rec the chair
recognizes um the Speaker of the House
Representative uh from lonary
representative Packard on uh s SP 317
great number 317 thank you Mr Speaker uh
well than thank you Mr chairman and
members of the committee uh Senator
Bradley couldn't be here today so he
asked me to introduce it for him and um
even though I am a sponsor of it and I
knew what it said I just R actually read
it today you know from top to bottom so
basically it sets up a New Hampshire
Ireland Trade
Commission and um I'm not going to go
through everything in the bill but um I
know I think we're the sixth largest
partner trading partner to is land and I
think you've all met or most of you
might have met Sergeant Mark I mean uh
Senator Mark
Daly and um you know he's been over here
and he called me Friday afternoon on my
way home and said can do you want me to
fly over for today's hearing I said
Senator I said it might last 15 20
minutes he says I don't care I'll be
over if you figure you need me so I I
told the senator I said I don't want you
flying from Ireland for a 10-minute
meeting but
uh if you want to that's fine but uh he
he didn't decided not to do it so this
basically sets up a trade Council so we
can work uh closer with our our Ireland
uh trade partners and uh I I don't I
don't see anything but good coming out
of it um it's about all I
got I mean it's it's um it's fairly
uncomplicated I hate to after being as
many years in this institution say that
this is a simple bill but I truly do
believe this is a uh fairly simple
straightforward
Bill and with that I'll try and answer
any questions that you may have Mr
chairman or members uh thank you Mr
Speaker I was going to ask you if you
would take any questions are there any
questions for representative Packard
representative Massa
MIP thank you Mr uh speaker I was just
wondering what precipitated this bill
now I think the the fact that
um um we we seem to have established a
much closer
relationship uh I was over there in 22
with ncsl one of the trips over there
and uh we spent three days with uh you
know Senator Daly you know when we were
over there and we started talking about
this kind of thing you know as far as
he'd like to set up a trade Council and
almost all the States you know all the
United States and each individual State
So that obviously we could um work
closer together but I think that we are
a little bit closer than some of the
other states seeing that um if you're if
you look at it it uh the the first
settlement was uh in nutfield which is
now part of my hometown netfield used to
Encompass London Derry parts of daily
parts of Manchester parts of Windham
until it was broken up
so there is a little bit of discussion
as to whether it was dairy or London
Dairy where the first potato was grown I
can tell you it was London Dairy I was
there thank you for that Mr
Speaker I uh read I also read the
measure and I saw the town of nutfield
and I thought I knew where every town
was in New hampsh sure but nutfield uh I
did not know until now uh the uh
technically it doesn't exist anymore
nutfield
okay uh there have been uh I I see the
measure calls for two representatives to
be in the trade Council there are a
number of volunteers who've already
stepped up to uh to uh fill that role uh
we can get you those names uh down the
road uh other questions go ahead M I've
I've had numerous requests that be on
the trade counsel yes not everybody
wants to be on a commission or a
committee but this one seems to call to
uh some of our
people anything else uh from the
committee representative
sherff Mr Speaker would you be amable to
stick around for an executive session
seeing how was shot a
body I would be a minimal to that yes
thank
you thank you OB sherff I was going to
point out that we are one shy of Corum
we had a request in yesterday to uh to
the office and uh with the powers vested
in the speaker I'm sure that uh that
that would work if you well we were just
talking about that over in the office
because I was under the impression you
were down too so we were just talking
about that so I I would give give me a
couple of minutes to make sure that um
they haven't already filled
it uh absolutely uh we will uh if
there's no other questions and no one no
uh did you give us a pink card Mr
Speaker we'll we'll fill it out we'll
fill it out for you representative
KY uh what opportunities do you see for
this trade Council in terms of improving
or expanding relationships with Ireland
well I I think uh you know our goal is
uh after um you know we spent when we
were when I was over there with uh the
ncsl delegation in uh 22 um we did talk
about the number of businesses that are
already
involved uh you know between our two
countries and um uh we hoping our you
know our hope is that this will
expand you know the cooperation between
our two countries and thus actually
hopefully uh increase the companies that
are doing a lot of trade with Ireland
and you know hire more people and uh and
then and obviously vice
versa anything
else representative Sebert hi thank you
for taking my question Mr Speaker um I
was just curious and it could just be me
but I was just wondering when I looked
at it online on the docket thing was
there an FN attached to this like a fun
thing or is that there anymore if you if
you look at the back uh it it it does
have a fiscal note and um as so many of
the bills that um we get uh this is
indeterminable at this time and it's
going to be um uh you know something
that's self-funded it's doesn't look
like it's going to require any state
funding okay all right thank you pres
Sheriff yeah just to follow up on that
question I think it's very comparable to
the Canadian American Trade Council
which Linda and I both belong to and I
think their funding is like $8,000 a
year that goes to the Secretary of State
to fund that and so I'm sure this would
be comparable and so when this bill came
to the floor it wouldn't have to go to
finances the second committee because
the funding amount is so small and and
and it is as the back says now it's
still indeterminable Yes you well know
Mr Speaker you went you and I went
through most of all the bills and how
many came up in determinable or the
fiscal no he turned into the uh clerk's
office when it's ready than not yeah
yeah
uh there's a good question rep seber the
the word indeterminable I've seen many
times uh not as many as I have Mr
Speaker if there are no further
questions Mr Speaker uh if you can help
us uh with that Quorum issue we need uh
the one more person and then we uh we'll
we'll exec this measure okay let me let
me uh let me find out if uh you know if
they've already got somebody appointed
or not and if not I can sit in uh
oh welcome I am
congratulations welcome uh now we need
you to uh leave that seat and take a
seat uh between these two reps over here
if you would or if you if You' prefer
another seat take you pick Mr Speaker Mr
Speaker this is called a battlefield
promotion I
believe uh want my seat set up here uh
Mr speak I
between those young reps would would
would work fine I think the between the
Roses uh represent sherff can say that I
would never
dare so at this time we're looking uh
when when Madame clerk is ready ready to
go into an exec session Madam Clark okay
uh we will uh expeditiously go to an
exec session and I am looking for a
motion uh representative shirtliff with
the green tie i' move move ought to pass
and I will second that Madam clerk uh
the motion is OTP ought to pass on the
appropriately numbered SB
uh
and uh Mr uh Mr Speaker uh represent
shortliffe would you care to speak to
your motion well I think as the bill
mentions there's a great history between
the United States and Ireland um you
know the towns were settled from people
from Northern Ireland and der Lyon der
in that area uh one of our Governors and
Civil War Revolutionary War General John
Sullivan was the son of immigrants from
County Cork Ireland the fact that here
in New Hampshire during the Great Irish
famine which really wasn't a famine
because grain was being shipped out of
Ireland it was the Shakers in New
Hampshire that sent food to the Irish
during that period and um I think like I
said that long con connection uh in the
fact that my own mother came here from
Ireland as a little girl uh before the
trouble started in Ireland because her
father was involved in the Irish
Republican Brotherhood and
um you know I think it's it's great that
we are finally doing this and I commend
the speaker for his work and getting
this legislation before this committee
and I had asked the committee to vote
out to pass it so we can get her on
consent thank you rob shortliffe um I
will add having seconded this motion
that uh my mother's uh grandmother was
also from County Cork my dad's family is
from gallway Bay Area it was a thrill to
visit there once I hope if whether
you're Irish or not that you get a
chance to visit the Emerald island and
I'm happy to second the motion uh any
other comments
questions um yes represent Lloyd just
for my own curiosity just so I can learn
a little a little bit um the uh 400
million in Granite State Goods uh sent
over there what uh what do we send
like the question is what goods do we
send is part of the trade relationship
what goods do we send uh
to uh Ireland I know representative
Pearl honeymoon there and I'm sure the
maple syrup uh is part of that equation
but Mr Speaker or does anyone have some
better information on
that unfortunately Mr chairman I I do
not have a list of all the companies
that we interact with uh some of them
were mentioned uh a couple years ago
when I was there and I'm sorry can't
remember that that is a very good
relevant question given the nature of
the measure and uh we will uh we'll find
that out especially if I end up on this
trade Council I will definitely get back
to you representative anything else
okay seeing that Madam clerk when you
were ready uh the motion is on to pass
on uh Senate Bill 317
317 um when you're ready okay
representative Rollins yes
representative
Packard representative Gagney of course
representative Manion yes representative
shirtliff yes representative Mass Milla
yes representative Cary yes
representative
tol oh no toll today representative
Lloyd yes representative O'Neal yes
representative
Sebert yes okay did I miss anyone chair
chair Cher says
I okay one two three four five six seven
eight nine 10
11 to nothing 11 to nothing 11 to
nothing uh this uh without objection
will uh head to the consent calendar and
on to the full floor it's already passed
the Senate obviously and um thank you so
much for uh helping us to get through
this um Mr Speaker representative
Packard and with
that we'll call an end to this uh
executive session we know two of you
have to go to a tra another trade
Council before you leave uh real quickly
uh as I've mentioned I sent everybody a
message uh we uh two things we have left
we have to take care of HR 31 and we
also have have request and if we if it's
granted to uh spend some more time on
the wording on
hcr8 uh we may be able to make an
announcement on Thursday and have a uh a
a session and finish everything on
Friday so uh if you can't make it Friday
we will need um uh Subs as as required
that's all that I have so we'll see you
uh in the big house on big house I mean
repul uh on on
Thursday I just I just want to thank the
committee thank you very
much committee this year so so I have a
I have a quick question before we all
leave should we not put this on consent
you the vote on this
absolutely uh Mr Speaker representative
KY makes a interesting point in question
uh as with the Taiwan resolution which
we did pull off consent so that we could
speak to that briefly in the floor uh do
you see any utility in in uh not putting
this on consent so that someone can
speak to it on the floor what is your
sense
I
okay
okay we will have a wonderful committee
report though guaranteed so thank you
for that that's a bit of
blond